(audience cheering and clapping)
- [Kelly] You look so nice.
- Thank you, I wore a suit
and everything for you, Kelly.
- I've never seen a dentist
that looks like you, my man.
- Ah!
- I was like, "What?"
- That's true, I was gonna be a dentist.
- [Kelly] You really were?
- I mean, that's what
I went to school for.
I was gonna, I got my degree in biology.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's so cool.
- With the intention to
go into dental school.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I think the reason
I wanted to do it was
because my mom pushed me
at an early age and say,
"What are you gonna do with your life?"
I was like, I'm an eighth grader.
I don't know.
- Yeah, what?
- So my sophomore year I told her
that I wanted to be a dentist because A
I could check off the
box of being a doctor,
which would please my mother.
- (laughs) Get it in there.
- And B I was always good at drawing and
and making things with my hands.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I think that was the reason.
And then, and then I got completely jaded
and moved to Los Angeles, and here we are.
- I know. It worked out.
(audience applauds)
It worked out for the better.
(Josh laughs)
I think. I think.
But you literally are just back
from your honeymoon, right?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Congratulations
on getting married.
(audience cheering)
- Mm-hmm. Thank you.
- [Kelly] That's awesome.
How was the honeymoon?
Oh my God, so great.
- [Josh] Look at that
beautiful Ralph Lauren suit.
Thank you.
- Yeah. Look at that dress.
I'm sorry, I wasn't looking at you.
Yeah, I'm like, "She looks beautiful."
- She is a little sweetheart.
And we had an amazing time in Thailand.
- [Kelly] Had you ever been?
- Have you been?
- I have been to Thailand, a few times.
- Well, it takes you about a
full 24 hours to get there.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So it took us a day or two
just to get acclimated to the time.
But we went to this beautiful
resort called Soneva
on this little island in Thailand
for about four or five days.
And then we went to Bangkok,
which is a complete-
- Totally different.
- Departure from the serenity of Soneva.
- Yeah, is it true that you had to go
to the emergency room, like
right before the wedding?
- [Josh] I did.
- That's a good start.
- Well, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tell me about it.
So it was like,
we had this amazing band
play for the rehearsal dinner
the night before.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
And we had a blast.
And afterwards we went into the party bus
to go back to the hotel and we had music
pumping in there.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I'm feeling good.
- [Kelly] Feeling good.
- So I decide I'm gonna start dancing.
And they have those handles
that you hold on in the party bus.
- So let loose.
- I tried to do this thing
where you like a gymnast,
like straighten myself out.
And I was like, "egh oh."
- Cause we have really good
ideas when we're inebriated.
- Something just happened.
(Kelly gasps)
(audience laughs)
And yeah, so I felt fine.
I got through that night and
I wake up the next morning,
two hours before the wedding
and I couldn't get out of bed.
I literally couldn't stand up.
So I was like, "What
am I gonna do? Oh my."
So they had to take me
to the emergency room,
give a bunch of meds, and
shoot me with Toradol.
- Oh my Gosh.
- And it was great.
Everything went great.
(audience laughing)
I got through the night.
- Of course it was, you're
on Toradol (laughs).
- Danced the night away, next
morning after the wedding.
Couldn't get out of bed again.
- [Kelly] Oh no.
- They had to take me
to the emergency room
again the next night.
And she's like, "Oh my God,
everything's fine here.
This is like the first day of my marriage,
and I'm wheeling my husband
around in a wheelchair."
I'm already way older than she is.
(laughing)
So it wasn't a great start.
- [Kelly] A funny one.
- But.
- [Kelly] Memorable.
- I was like, Babe, for better or worse.
- Yeah. You said so, I heard it.
(audience laughing and applauding)
That's incredible.
So your honeymoon was in Thailand,
but you also just posted this.
Oh, I love this.
- [Josh] Oh yeah.
This is my cabin out in Minnesota.
- [Kelly] Who's getting
hypothermia in the-
- So that's my cousin Dallas.
What we do is we take a chainsaw,
and cut a big hole in the ice.
- [Kelly] Yeah, to go ice fishing.
- Well, no, no, no.
You do ice plunge,
you get into the water and you, like-
- And some of us ice fish.
- Yes. Some people ice fish.
We get into the water and we ice fish.
But we have this old wood burning stove
that we found on the property years ago
that had turned into like,
some kind of a fishing shed.
And we realize, no, this is a,
like, an old wood burning sauna.
So you put wood in the
side of it, it heats up.
And that's like the, you know,
the Scandinavians used to do it.
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- So we'll go into the ice,
then we'll get in the the
sauna and go back and forth.
- That's so cool.
Do you find that important?
I have a ranch.
I go escape and I like
getting out of the city.
- Yep.
- Is that important to you?
- Oh my gosh.
It's everything for me, I mean, it's,
for me to get, I always say
every time I get out there
it's like my blood pressure drops about
twenty-five percent
- [Kelly] Yeah.
And then you question life decisions
and, like, why you leave.
- Yeah. What am I living
in Los Angeles for?
How can I figure out a
way to live here forever?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Because there's
something about, I think,
just getting back to
the basics of, I mean,
when we first started, we had nothing.
I had a little cabin in the woods
with no electricity, no water.
- Yeah.
- And we sort of, over
time, have now built it
into this beautiful
little place that we just
- Spot you go to, yeah.
- Love going to.
And I do things there
that I never do here.
Like, I don't even mow my own lawn here.
- Yeah. But somehow you,
but I jump on a tractor on my ranch,
but I don't do it here.
- [Josh] I have a tractor too.
- Me too. But I don't, yeah.
- I'm on my tractor, I'm on my skid steer.
I'm shoveling dirt,
I'm taking out stumps.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I mean, for whatever reason.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you.
- All right.
- But for whatever reason, when I'm here.
- Moving dirt really gets her going.
It's like amazing. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
- When I'm here, I have no,
I have no motivation
to do it when I'm here.
- No, because you're busy here.
- [Josh] Yeah.
- We work so much here.
- [Josh] I guess.
- But whenever I'm there I do.
I love getting on.
- I have a zero turn lawn mower.
- [Josh] You have a tractor too?
Yes. But my zero turn is my
favorite thing to get on.
I will, I'll literally,
I'll keep coming by my
sister and be like, I swear
to God, I'm almost done.
I'm almost done.
No, I'm not.
- Two hours later.
- Two hours later. Yeah. I love it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. I love all of it.
- There's something
cathartic about getting on
a piece of equipment where you
can actually do stuff with.
Because until I had those things
it took us forever to get anything done.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then once I had
my Bobcat, I was like.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I was like getting real work done.
- So you spend some time at
the cabin with your dad, right?
- Yeah, my dad's the
reason I have the place
he found the property
for me back in, I don't
know, 15 years ago.
- Oh, that's cool.
- And I never had a boat.
I never grew up on a lake or anything.
So it was, it's like a
full learning curve for me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
And so I had a boat for the first time
but it was like,
my dad loves when I say this,
he's a total bargain shopper.
He finds like deals.
He's always finding a
deal on a car, a boat.
- [Kelly] That's smart.
- A four wheeler.
It's great.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Sometimes they work out,
sometimes not so much.
The boat, we tried it on the water.
It starts right up.
I'm like, it was like a celebration.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like, oh my God.
We're on a boat.
- Yeah
- We're moving.
- I'm on a boat, it's a song.
- And then, I put it in drive, nothing.
- [Kelly] What?
- I put it in reverse
and we start going back.
I'm like, so my boat works,
but it only goes in reverse.
(audience laughing)
- Please tell me you went around
the lake going in reverse.
- For like two hours.
(laughing)
(audience applauding)
- We went around that lake for two hours,
mostly because we were waiting for him
to come back around at the
at the public access to come pick us up.
But me and my buddy Björk
had one beer to share.
I mean that was-
- [Kelly] (laughs) To share?
- It's not that we're going in reverse.
It's having one beer to share.
We figured it was gonna be 10 minutes.
- That's friendship
when you share the beer.
- Yeah.
- But speaking of wait,
So tell us about the new season.
I love the Mighty Ducks, the movies
but I also love Game Changers.
I love this series.
- Thank you.
- You watching it?
- [Kelly] Yes. Me and my kids love it.
And honestly, I don't even need
to say that it's just for kids.
I watch it without my kids.
It's so good. I love it.
- [Josh] Oh, thank you, thank you.
- Yeah
- [Josh] Yeah, it's-
- I love the movies.
- Yeah, me too.
Well, I grew up, like I said,
in North Dakota and they were
the whole story originated in Minnesota.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so I always felt a
connection to it there.
I played hockey growing up and
when they asked me if I wanted to do this
I hadn't skated for like 35
years, by the way, until this.
I was like, Bambi out on the ice.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It was not pretty.
And the first five minutes on the ice
they had me doing these drills
and I literally had to
say, hold on, hold on.
And I had to leave the ice
and throw up in a garbage can.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Yeah. It wasn't pretty.
- I bet my thighs would just burn.
- Well it's just you're using
all these muscles you're
not used to using.
- Yeah.
- And you're trying so hard
to make them look like yeah
I could pretend to be a pro.
It wasn't, it wasn't,
It took me a good three weeks to get
comfortable.
- [Kelly] Oh man.
But yeah, the show has been
such a pleasant surprise
because I mostly took
the job in the beginning
because I wanted to be home.
I wanted to be able to
take my kid to school-
- Yeah, me too.
- And sleep in my own bed.
I was gone so much the year before
and I loved Lauren Graham.
I love the Mighty Ducks.
So I was like, you know what, let's do it.
This will be fun.
And I turned out to have the best time.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Cause these kids are awesome.
- [Kelly] It's a great cast.
- Like, they're really sweet.
They're unaffected.
They're well adjusted.
They work hard.
They're talented.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And they have fun.
- Yeah, I imagine it's
fun working with the kids.
Did I hear that they were like off camera,
like were they rapping or
something and you involved?
- So, Max Simkins and
a few of the other ones
are really, really good
musicians and it's singers.
- [Kelly] That's cool.
Yeah, Luke is an amazing singer
and DJ is this,
he can take two pens and
make any beat you want.
And so these kids in between
setups started doing this.
I was like, what is he freestyle
raps, DJ's doing the beat.
There's Luke on the thing.
And they all just sort of like,
Oh, so when I directed
my episode, episode seven
which will be coming up soon.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I asked them, "Have you guys
ever done this on camera?"
And they said, "No."
And I said, "Let me talk to the bosses
and see if they'll let me do it."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
So they yeah, they let me,
I asked them to go make
a rap based on the story
that we were telling
and it's in the episode
and they just crushed it.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- They crushed it.
It wasn't even part of this episode.
And these kids are just so talented.
(audience applauding)
- What I love most about that too
is you're giving them an experience
that sometimes I hear from
actors doesn't happen.
You know, having freedom and
like implementing your ideas
or like being inspired in the moment.
Like sometimes there's not that freedom.
That's a really cool
thing for them to know
that that can happen at such
a young age in this industry.
- Yeah, I think so.
I mean and for me that's part of the fun.
That's the reason why we do this is to-
- [Kelly] Be inspired by each other.
- And do what you're good at.
They're obviously all good actors,
but they're really good musicians too.
I was like-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Let's find a way to
make it work for the show.
And they killed it.
- It's a different kind of
depth too for the characters.
I like that.
So you have some other
fun projects out now.
Can you tell us about them?
- I also have a movie out,
two movies, one called Bandit.
Which is based on this,
it's a true story about
this this bank robber Galvin
or Gilbert Galvan who robbed
59 banks in the eighties.
- [Kelly] Whoa.
He was good at it.
- It's one of my favorite
movies I've ever done
because I got to, he was notorious
for having all these crazy
disguises when you go in.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And was able to get
out of them very quickly.
So that's out now.
And there's a movie
called Blackout on Netflix
which is also doing really well.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I just wanted to say check it out.
(audience cheering)
- I love that.
Well, you have a lot of things happening.
That's a lot of things all at once.
- Yeah.
Well, The Mighty Ducks:
Game Changer Season two
is on Disney Plus.
Y'all have to go watch it.